toute cette zone là c'est le rond point
c'est leur emploi le rond point il est
mis dans le champ il ne décolère pas ses
habitants de trappes s'opposent depuis
plusieurs semaines à la création d'un
futur rond-point à quelques mètres
seulement de leur jardin
ici à l'intersection de la nationale 10
et la route départementale 23 un projet
inscrit dans le cadre de l'enfouissement
partiel de la n10 présenté comme une
amélioration de l'insertion urbaine par
la commune ces habitants niveau eu que
des problèmes à pollution le bruit les
accélérations les coups de klaxon même
même les gyrophares dépoli de police
pompiers
c'est intenable s'est déjà intenable
actuellement donc le long de nos os et
c'est pas possible ça va être
insupportable pour la cinquantaine de
riverains concernés l'enfouissement
partiel prévue sur 400 m doit être
prolongée sur l' axe de son côté la
mairie qui porte ce projet depuis
presque 20 ans n'a pas voulu répondre à
nos questions
le maire ne souhaite pas répondre pour
le moment et le fera une fois la
déclaration d'utilité publique publiée
en effet il ne souhaite pas répondre sur
des travaux dont le maître d'oeuvre est
l'état attrape les nuisances causées par
la n 10 ont dénoncé depuis la création
de lacs ce milieu des années 50 jusqu'à
80 mille véhicules par jour l'empreinte
en direction de paris ou de rambouillet
les premiers travaux devraient débuter
en 2018 pour un coût total de 95
millions d'euros